Let's go back to now using this idea to count the number of steps in Russian as a function of a.
The thing that you should be noticing here is we now know the number of times
this loop is going to be executed.
This is the floor log base 2 of a plus 1.
For each of those times, how many statements get executed?
Well, there are these two statements that get executed unconditionally.
Then there is plus this conditional statement--this evaluation here get executed.
These three things get executed, and this additional for statement only gets executed
when x is odd.
As we talked about before, that happens however many times as there are 1 bits
in the binary representation of a.
That actually is enough to get us our answers.
Let me write it down.
How many steps is it going to take to execute russian(a, b)?
Well, as I said, the floor log base 2 of a rounded down plus 1
is the number of times the while loop is executed.
There are three statements that are going to executed inside
plus the additional three statements that are executed outside
plus there is going to be one statement executed for each of the bits of a that it's on
and particularly the summation. That's kind of a mess.
We can make it slightly less of a mess if we notice that this is upper bounded by
4 times the rounded down logarithm of a plus 7.
The reason for that being that the most number of on bits you can have in a number
is if all the bits are on and how many bits can you have in a number.
Well, if you have a number like this--a binary number like that,
each time you halve it, you're chopping off one of the bits.
The rounded down log base 2 of the number plus 1 is actually a count of the maximum
number of bits that you can have on.
Now, one thing that I'd like to point out here is that this quantity is much,
much, much, much, much less in general than some linear function in a
like what we get for naive.
Naive grows a lot faster--in fact, exponentially faster--literally exponentially faster
than the bound on the running time is for Russian.
Naive--very, very bad. Russian--actually quite good and happy.